now if you've been following the news
recently you might remember this from
sagittar java just yesterday
the uk health security agency estimates
that the current rate of date the
current number of daily infections are
around 200
000. two hundred thousand
daily infections it's a really striking
number we had it on the news last night
so did lots of the newspapers actually
have a look at this front page of the
times you can see there it is right at
the front two hundred thousand daily uh
omicron infections same thing if you
looked at the front of the guardians so
this really was big news uh even
actually the ft uh had it on their front
page very serious newspaper two hundred
thousand omicron infections daily
it begs a question doesn't it where is
this number actually coming from is it
new intelligence privileged information
that the ukhs say the health security
agency has or is it something else
well 24 hours on i think i've worked it
out it is actually a back of an envelope
some that 200 000 comes from something
i'm going to show you right now which
any of us could really have worked out
and it begins with this okay i'm going
to show you exactly how they did it this
is case numbers so that's just your
number the one we see every day of daily
cases uh that's a seven day average and
what you'll probably remember is there's
a difference between cases positive
tests tests coming back positive
and infections infections is a kind of
modeled number where you're working out
how many people across the population
have covered at any given time in this
case this is new infections each day and
what you can see and what will be pretty
obvious to you is that there's a
difference see that blue line the case
is on the 21st of november it was about
35 000 on the same day infection's about
78 thousand so that is always higher
because you've got people who who aren't
getting tested basically and so what the
uk hsa did is they took that 78 000
number and they
kind of presumed and this is fine that
it was the same in early december as it
was in late november because we don't
have that data yet 78 thousand
then they went to the fact that we can't
we know that at that time broadly about
20 of the sequence cases were coming
back as omicron so they assumed at that
point
20 just over 20
that worked out as that dot over there
you can just about see it the red dots
23 000 omicron infections on the 7th of
december so 7th of december last week
but how do you get from that 23 000 to
that scary 200 000 number well let me
show you so we'll take this there's that
same dot and what we're going to do is
just double it we're doubling it every
two days actually just under every two
days every 1.9 days and you get that
line doubling every 1.9 days you get
that exponential increase you can see
the curve you'll be familiar with it
from all of the covert uh period when
you've been looking at those charts and
if you follow that line lo and behold on
the 13th of december 207 000 omicron
infections new infections on that day so
it is right according to this but it is
a back of an envelope uh some but it is
at that kind of level by the way that's
england it's not the uk as a whole 200
000 for england if you're talking about
uk as a whole you're probably up to
about 250 000 maybe even more
but what happens next if you follow that
line if you follow that logic then right
now we've got 300 000. so today one day
on three hundred thousand and by the end
of the week by saturday you're talking
about an extra 1.3 million on saturday
new daily cases on saturday now already
200 000 is the highest we have ever seen
if indeed it is true 1.3 million would
be just crazy numbers and by christmas
day
25th of december we can't even fit it in
here because it's so high up there it's
kind of well above the roof of the
studio you're talking about 17
million omicron infections on that day
and just bear in mind that's on that day
if you were to work out all of the kind
of cumulative infections you've had over
this period well
everyone in england would have it 55
million people in england would have it
just on the basis on the logic of this
line that the health secretary was
basing that 200 000 figure on it doesn't
mean it's invalid you know there is
definitely cause and use for these
things when we don't have the data to
back it up but nonetheless it's worth
just being clear where that number
actually came from it's also worth being
clear if you take a different assumption
about how fast you're doubling uh those
case numbers or those infection numbers
rather you get very different results so
just recently just last week the ukhsa
was talking about maybe cases uh
doubling where infections doubling about
2.5 days so that's at a slower rate and
2.5 days gives you this line still very
fast increase but nowhere near looking
like we that red line so by yesterday
the day that saturday was talking about
200 000 actually 120 000 omicron cases
not quite a record but certainly high
levels and by christmas well 3.4 million
on the day which is certainly very high
indeed certainly seems implausible but
nowhere near 17 million nowhere near
everyone in england
having had uh omicron but you know
laughing at this and to some extent it
is a reduction absurdum uh is to
undermine the fact that really there is
a serious point here which is that cases
are going up they are unlikely to go up
as half as fast as that or certainly
they're unlikely to continue going up as
fast as that in south africa we know
that they did go up at that rate for a
while and then they started to slow so
then it was kind of right now as far as
i can tell it's doubling maybe nine uh
every nine every ten days but when you
look at the actual data about what's
happening certainly the figures are
rising not quite as fast as that but
certainly rising these dots here just
showing you those case numbers across
the uk so actual cases that we're
detecting and the latest figure 59 610
new cases close to a daily record and if
you just look at the kind of seven day
average well look at that black line it
is going up and i think pretty soon
maybe by the end of the week certainly
by next week we're likely to see a
record number
of cases
but here's the thing as we should know
this already but it's worth just
underlining it it's not really all about
that line it's about this line as well
this is admissions for to hospitals and
what you can probably make out is those
two lines very correlated uh in those
early parts of the cro of the pandemic
you can see at the start there we didn't
have much testing but emissions were
high but look at that second wave you
can see those lines really correlated
with each other and look at what's
happened since doing kind of as a result
in part of the vaccination program you
can see admissions very low while cases
are high and so the real thing we're
going to have to focus on is not just
that black line or indeed the line that
the health secretary was talking about
about infections but also what's going
on with emissions what's going on in
healthcare and if there's one part of
the country right now which is worth
focusing on especially
it's london because you've got a really
high increase in london just look at
that line uh for cases the black line
for cases in london at the moment nearly
vertical going up very fast there is a
lot of omicron uh in london that seems
to be the the epicenter but still
admissions is going to be the big
question
so keeping an eye on that red line and
working out whether it's going to go up
that is the thing that we're going to
have to be doing over the course of the
next few weeks